[Musik]
richtet sowie das muss ganz furchtbar
die beta nicht nur die bewegungen machen
merke dass ich die buskosten egger hält
lasten des netbooks groß ist das muss
für eine kreisreform furchtbar furchtbar
trotzdem suchen immer mehr menschen dass
schnee abenteuer abseits der piste wie
aber kann und soll man mit dem
lawinenrisiko umgehen
davon handelt dieser film
einen solchen bart tragen in der regel
propheten oder gurus ich habe den 73
jährigen werner munter im wallis
aufgesucht der bergführer hat jahre lang
als privatgelehrter die geheimnisse des
schnees erforscht so wurde er zum
international gefragten lawinenexperten
man nennt ihn deshalb auch den lawinen
papst werden und was hat sich
klavierhocker eingang teile findet es
faszinierend naturphänomen
wir haben ja immer wieder größte gefahr
ausgesetzt von möglichst nach also wenn
ein ereignis ein remake analog für den
flug an interessanten methodisch sondern
nur einen trend spricht von new york ich
glaube bisher nach deich vor allem das
treffen wo ihnen gibt in der lawine
hatte sich lebensgefahr
wer unter vier stunden im schnee lag die
chance die rechtliche struktur aus dass
man hals gehabt aber das braucht
europäische opel drückt auf dem marine-
und also von klausuren mit dem x 45
minuten sehr gut doppelt nach einem
tieflader graf das geld die region
minute also die vierte stimmung ist tot
wer denkt bei sonne und guter laune
schon an ein solches szenario der
gamestop andermatt ist eine top
destination für variantenfahrer
für die sicherheit am berg ist dieser
mann verantwortlich in seiner haut
möchte ich nicht stecken
[Musik]
es ist carlo danioth bergführer und chef
pisten und rettungsdienst am gemsstock
suchen die freerider ihre eigene
abfahrts linie der ganze berg sieht aus
wie ein morscher baumstamm der von
borkenkäfern zerfressen wurde
da j zeigt mir ein paar müsterchen wo
und wie die freerider ihrem adrenalin
kick holen
noch zögert dieser snowboardfahrer ob er
es wagen soll dass nordkorea unter ihm
ist steil und voller triebschnee das
heißt automatisch hohes schneebrett
risiko
und schon löst sich die lawine ursache
lockerer schnee der durch die
gewichtsbelastung des nö was abgeht dem
freerider scheint es egal zu sein wobei
andere schneesportler gefährdet in einem
affentempo stürzt sich der fahrer in die
steile rinne have fun lautet sein motto
besser wäre check the risk
größte problem mit der freiheit sehen
der sich schnell ein schneebrett
ausgelöst werden die spiels immer der
größten hektik das muss schnell dass
gott umzieht wenn man immer schnell
hoch- oder will überleben muss man
möglichst schnell musste sie ist als ich
es geht der größten hektik zweiter
frequenz frauen und da sind die letzten
jahren zur abstützung fall im sehr
steilen klein
man löst das krisen schneebrett los oder
ein fahrfehler oder materialfehler und
das 15 absturz über 20 erklärt das kommt
zu schweren verletzungen führen weil die
ihnen dann der rettungsdienst gefordert
ist
wie soll man mit der tödlichen lawine
der weißen gefahr umgehen
unterschreibt alle seine beobachtungen
in schwarze notizbücher bei meinem
besuch ist er gerade auf der seite 6164
angelangt ist die geschichte für alle
getötet aus kursrisiko das heißt
zwischen kosmos akzeptabel niederschlag
2011 ein kälte gar nicht traute wenn
wenn wenn sie trocken ist als die lawine
kommt dann ist so definiert werde stufe
ist die rente waagschale
die redaktions faktor in der
erwachsenen- und dem gleichgewicht denn
es ist kurz risiko mich als abstraktes
drücken
wer vorsichtsmaßnahme angemessen ist
denn ist nicht gut
mit seiner reduktions methode 3 x 3 watt
motor die lawinenkunde revolutioniert
ein beispiel ist die lawinengefahr
erheblich braucht das risiko vermindern
der faktoren wie keine hänge gehen die
steirer als 30 grad sind oder
konsequentes auslassen von nord
expositionen mutters ansichten leuchten
ein nun wollte ich wissen wie man sich
das entsprechende know-how praktisch
aneignen kann beispielsweise in einem
lawinen kurs beim skc den
schweizerischen alpenclub von realp aus
bei miesem wetter die gruppe ins volker
gebiet aufbricht
die unterkunft liegt auf 2.100 meter
über meer
das heißt gut zwei stunden fell aufstieg
bergführer willi arnold aus schattdorf
leitet den kurs mit dabei ist erich als
er geht auf die 70 zu und ist mitglied
der sp sektion rosberg zug
nach einer kurzen schlussabfahrt wird
die unterkunft in tiefenbach glücklich
erreicht wieso macht ihrig alb den kurs
eine wichtige motivation ist sie ja das
ist ja was hand wo kolleg wo es ist der
sektion ging aber wiederholt davos und
das ist dann so groß ich fahre bei mir
sein club kollege überlebte das
schneebrett nicht
noch haben die kursteilnehmer keine
ahnung was sie nach dem lager bezug
erwartet während der leiter dani arnold
mit der gruppe eine erste theorie
lektion befüllt bereiten seine drei
bergführer kollegin anne lawinen übung
vor fünf verschütteten suchgeräte oder
lvs werden in seseke gesteckt und
weiträumig vergraben
realitätsnah
durchschnittlich schönste geschichte
regel meter und das ist nur richtig dass
nachher sondieren und nachher glaube
dass man die glaubt echten kracher in
der presse
zum schluss press terra truck den schnee
wie bei einer lawine noch fest zusammen
und schon erscheinen die kursteilnehmer
angeführt von bergführer uhr liam und
bergführer michelle alles andere gibt
alles
[Musik]
ich möchte hier wichtige homer und sagen
das navi ist ein paar zuschauer ganz
wichtig erich alb kümmert sich zuerst um
den einzigen nicht verschüttet sämtliche
suchgeräte der helfer müssen sofort vom
senden auf opfersuche umgestellt werden
sonst würden die retter sich gegenseitig
als ebenfalls verschütteten orten
3 vorstellen search search so schuster
die richtig schwierig alles scheint auf
der richtigen spur zu sein
[Musik]
wenn die routine fehlt werden auch die
einfachsten handgriffe knifflig das
zusammensetzen der sondierstangen zum
beispiel dann geht wertvolle zeit
verloren
paradox die rettungs ausbildung macht
man nicht für sich selbst sondern für
seinen kameraden der unter der lawine
liegt vielleicht wäre ich alt glaubt ein
zweites opfer orten zu können
zwar ist es nur eine übung und doch ist
die hektik spürbar groß
festgesetzt
ja ich danke sie sich sicher das ist
hier relativ lange bis sie ein lvs
seehofer machen oder das ist recht viel
zeit verloren aber war das noch lieber
nicht stoppen oder aber es ist natürlich
realität ist schlechter schwieriger wird
es ewig so blöd sind am abend auf aber
es also passieren oder comics welches
material auseinander und das war gut so
und jetzt ist so dass man sagt ich
endlich richtig amazon.de stache pinguin
position zwischen der sache steht
die sonde von er ich will immer noch
nicht allen schwierigkeiten zum trotz
nach 13 minuten sind alle seseke
ausgegraben ein gutes resultat
statistik seit 80 prozent von anna
wienen umfang also bewusst natürlich
challenge dass alle zusammen aber so
realistisch war das szenario wenn
natürlich viel flieht in aller welt
haben
technisch ist es nicht optimal gelaufen
sind sie schon morgen vielleicht setzen
wir mal mitgerissen
trotzdem blicken an der oberfläche sie
aber jetzt mal wie abgehakt stark an
jenes läuft los wurde wie aber
sicherlich auch der abgang wenn ihre
maschine ihnen die ganze ist auch also
nicht mit reid und clyde und teilt aber
ich habe wirklich einmal probiert
krampfen und kalendern an der oberfläche
bietet zum glück aber das ist eine das
riesa praxis eigentlich glück kommt
das wird ein langer tag nach dem
abendessen müssen die kurs teilnehmer
die bevorstehende ski tour vorbereiten
was die möglichkeit einen monat vor
allem im sektor not oder das grillen
trio dann ist er hilft also nur zwei
alternativen wenn wir uns die
biotechnologie stehe die
schlüsselstellen oder ein
oberflächengewässer
ein fantastischer morgen auf 4k
tiefenbach bespricht eine sonnige tour
[Musik]
bis zum ziel fehlen erich und seiner
gruppe happige 1300 höhenmeter gewinnt
also gute sicht und lawinensituation
ja ich nicht wirklich die hat da
eigentlich tue ich große manko steilhang
der anstieg durch stellen konnte man
also plötzlich dem sie ist als
schriftsteller definierten und es stellt
sich fragen ob ein bisschen unvermögen
und spur arbeit ist wirklich erachte ich
noch genau an den moment und ich danke
dass wir durch den strang warten bis der
duft megawatt
nach und nach ziehen wolken auf
das macht die orientierung nicht
einfacher starker wind macht die finger
klamm
die kälte beißt die letzten konturen
verschwinden und erich spürt seine beine
die sicht ist minimal geworden
die teilnehmer haben keine chance mehr
abzuchecken ob sie plötzlich in einen
lawinen angeraten der über 30 grad steil
ist das aber wäre nach mutter drei mal
drei berlin in stufe erheblich ein ganz
schlechtes risiko mehr ist wie erich ein
wenig mulmig zumute vor der abfahrt es
ist heikel praktisch ohne sich dem wald
einen steilhang herunterzufahren
erich hat das heil geschafft wir sind
wieder zurück in tiefenbach
zum abschluss demonstrierte uhr jahren
und zwei moderne lawinen geräte im vbb
das system erzeugt problem ich sicher
war dem skifahrer waren stieg weniger
lawinen auslösen dass ich das deutsche
publikum dankt dem schnorchel gerät kann
der verschüttete auch in einer lawine
länger unverbrauchte luft einatmen
es wiegt das hilfsmittel wo ein gewimmel
mails neuen bereich das thema wichtig
der airbag rucksack märz das ganze
system war ich mit so einer pause fand
er funktioniert jetzt wenn ich merke ich
möchte der abfahrt durchkommen in der
wiener der 10er einfach damals betrieb
der ballon kann den skifahrer
möglicherweise von verschüttet werden in
der lawine bewahren dieser freerider hat
es geschafft in auslöse griff seines
airbags zu ziehen mit viel glück
schrammte an den felsen vorbei
hilfsmittel wie der rettungs balance
sind allerdings dann kontraproduktiv
wenn sie nur die risikobereitschaft
steigern
[Musik]
der spruch ist nicht ganz richtig denn
die sechs uhr ist und helfern
also ich finde kalkulierte risiken mit
sich
das ist kurz risiko oder gar nicht
möglich sagt vater machen und auf dem
friedhof
das ist doch nicht aus dass ein freund
einer steilen abfahrt im um verspätete
klein
das ist doch völlig klar
[Musik]